What's really important is for this second guy to, one, not leave early,
but, two, almost creep the space a little bit closer to this first receiver.
Because when I go off and Dom's a little bit tighter here, this guy's on an island.
He has to make a decision whether he's going after Dom or leaving the space open.
So just try that.
Everybody got that?
Yeah.
All right.
Yeah, Rick.
No over-the-top balls.
Everything's got to be before.
Nice, Dom.
Well done, Dom.
Beautiful.
Nice, Ricky.
Well done, Ricky.
Way to finish, Allie.
Great hands, Kenny.
Hey.
Nice and tight, nice and tight.
Nice.
Nice job, Mark.
Straight back, straight back.
Swap defense.
Take yellow cards.
That's fine.
Me, me, me, me.
Great hands, Joe.
Lovely.
My turn.
My turn, my turn.
Go middle, Allie.
Go carry.
My turn, my turn.
Watch out Joe. Oh my god, they missed a rep because of you.
Here, let's see that mustache again.
Nice! Good transfer!
Oh, you do play sense. You are in sense.
Swap!
Dickhead.
Go for the man, not the ball. Make a decision. Nice Tom. Great hands. Nice. Way to hold your depth Joe.
Too late brother.
There was no defense there.
Brennan held his feet. I was going to make that quick tap.
Nice Robert.
Perk suck.
How are you sweating out here? It's freezing.
Dude, focus. Here it comes.
Commit one of the boys.
Commit to a man.
Nice!
With your hands.
Pull back. Pull back.
Oh!
Swap D!
What's behind you there Dylan?
Just keep chatting defense, yeah?
Deep corey, deep corey, deep corey.
Nice powers.
Yeah, with me, with me.
Yeah, we got three.
Yeah, we got one.
Get down.
Oh!
Time you lost man there Kenny.
Get in there.
Get one!
Get hands, get hands.
Real deep, real deep.
Two.
Still holding, still holding.
Yeah, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh!
Video!
Turn, turn, turn. Next rep, next rep.
No, no, you're good.
They're pushing though.
Alex is an overachiever.
Dummy Alex.
One more.
That was just a little forward.
Dummy him if you get the ball on the way back.
I'll give it a look. I'll give it a look.
He's going to go so fast.
Got his arm.
I'm coming in flat, bro.
I'm out.
You're three.
I'm two back.
Hey!